Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Patentengespräch durschen. Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Vielen Dank. Kurz zum Amblach, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Dann können wir zur aktuellen Bescheid werden übergehen. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, melden Sie sich dabei mit mir.
Ja, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedrich Meier.
Sie sind mit C, H, Friedrich und Meier mit A oder E.
Mit E, I.
E, I. Okay. Herr Meier, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt und bin am 15. Februar 1967 geboren.
67 geboren. Okay. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie, Herr Meier?
Ich bin 1 Meter 74 groß und 78 kg.
Okay, Herr Meier, vielen Dank für die Informationen. Was führt Sie so ums? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe bemerkt, dass ich in den letzten Tagen und Wochen schlecht Luft bekomme.
Vor allem, wenn ich so treppen steige, habe ich den Eindruck, ich kriege keine Luft.
Mir drückt das Deboost ab und ich habe auch ungefähr 20 kg Gewicht verloren in den letzten vier Monaten.
In den letzten vier Monaten?
Haben Sie Husten bemerkt oder?
Nee, Husten habe ich nicht.
Besonders, seit ein paar Monaten diese Beschwerden abgetreten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Beschwerden im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtet hatten.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, Atemnot haben Sie bemerkt am Anfang?
Nee, gar nicht. Ich habe gemerkt, je mehr ich treppen steige, desto mehr wird die Luft.
Ich glaube, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie auf der Beine eine Schwellung bemerkt, geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Nee, geschwollene Beine habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Flachliegen?
Ich meine, brauchen Sie mehr als ein Kissen zu schlafen, zwei oder drei Kissen beim Liegen zum Schlafen?
Haben Sie Schlaffprobleme zum Beispiel?
Nee, beim Schlafen habe ich diese Probleme nicht und flach liegen kann ich auch.
Wenn diese Atemnot-Attacke kommt, haben Sie das Gefühl, als ob jemand auf Ihre Brust sitzen würde oder ein ingege Gefühl oder Beklemmung, haben Sie solche Beschwerden bemerkt?
Also so enge Gefühl nicht, aber ich kriege einfach keine Luft.
Also wenn ich treppen steige, dann fehlt mir einfach die Luft.
Es ist so, als wenn plötzlich keine Luft mehr da ist.
Okay, okay. Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben innerhalb vier Monaten ungefähr 20 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit, Erbrechen, etwa so?
Noch mal bitte.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder mussten Sie sich als sonst mehr als übergeben?
Nee, Übelkeit oder Erbrechen habe ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Husten und haben Sie Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe nicht Fieber gemessen, aber ich glaube, ich habe auch keinen Fieber gehabt, das war mir nie so heiß gewesen.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Probleme beim Schlafen, aber in der Schlaftunat zum Beispiel, mussten Sie Unterhämde wechseln?
Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder etwa so?
Sie meinen in der Nacht, ob ich da bin?
Ja, in der Nacht.
Ja, also in den letzten Wochen schon öfter, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Familie eine Krebserkrankung bekannt?
Nee, also in meiner Familie gab es bisher keinen Krebsfall.
Okay. Sind Sie gesund?
Wie meint ihr das?
Ja, ja, meine Eltern, sie sind 66 Jahre alt und ich lebe sie schon.
Ob meine Eltern noch leben?
Nee, die leben schon lange nicht mehr.
Okay.
Das tut mir leid.
Okay, Sie haben Sie gesagt und haben Sie eine bestimmte Spannungsgefühl oder Schmerzen in der Warte bemerkt?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Was fühlen Sie in letzter Zeit erschöpft, müde und gibt es Probleme beim täglichen Erledung zu machen?
Fühlen Sie sich allgemein, wie fühlen Sie sich?
Also in den letzten Wochen bin ich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ich bin eigentlich ein sehr, sehr dynamischer Mensch und ich war ziemlich aktiv, aber es fühlt mir alles sehr schwer.
Und am liebsten möchte ich einfach irgendwo liegen oder sitzen bleiben.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlwack oder beim Masselassen?
Ich meine, beim Stuhl haben Sie ein Blut oder etwas Ungewöhnliches, wie eine Therstuhl bemerkt?
Nee, nee, also Stuhlgangsproblem habe ich nicht und auch Fälligkeiten sind mir auch nicht aufgereicht.
Okay, auch Wasser lassen, ja?
Auch beim Wasserlassen, kein Problem.
Okay, das freut mich.
Husten habe ich gefragt.
Als sonst möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen über Ihre Beschwerden, etwas Begleitsymptome.
Ich möchte etwas kurz zusammenfassen.
Seit mehr als zwei Monaten haben Sie, fühlen Sie sich müde, erschöpelt, abgelegenheit.
Und Sie haben innerhalb vier Monaten 20 kg abgenommen.
Und Husten habe ich Sie nicht.
Und Sie haben keine Probleme beim Schlafen, um Zwei Kisten zu benutzen oder etwas Ähnliches.
Aber Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen, keine Husten.
Sie klagen über Nachtschweiß.
Und ich glaube, das ist alles.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, das ist alles.
Ich würde nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Alpkrankungen wie zum Beispiel, Bluthochdruck?
Bluthochdruck habe ich nicht und Zucker habe ich auch nicht.
Aber mein Arzt hat vor Jahren mal gesagt, ich hätte so etwas wie COPD.
Okay, ich verstehe jetzt COPD.
Nehmen Sie eine bestimmte Medikamente dagegen, wie Spray oder Tablete?
Also ich habe so einen Spray.
Wenn es mal ganz eng wird mit der Luft, soll ich das dann einmal einnehmen.
Salbutamol ist das, glaube ich.
Und das nehme ich dann bei Bedarf.
Aber als Dauermedikation nehmen Sie keine Medikamente dagegen, COPD?
Nee, nee, also ich habe es ja nie gebraucht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Nein?
Gibt es noch etwas außer COPD, eine bestimmte Erkrankung?
Nee, ich bin nicht bekannt.
Okay, okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Meier?
Nee, ich habe nicht operiert worden.
Sehr gut, das freut mich.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Weil es ist so möglich, um diese Lungekrankheiten,
vielleicht Lungekrankheiten, Menschen, hat eine Allerbischof,
Blühne oder etwas, haben Sie diese Allergien?
Nee, Allergien sind mir auch nicht bekannt.
Sehr gut.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Meier?
Ja, leider.
Okay, wie viel Zigaretten pro Tag?
Also ungefähr eine Packung am Tag.
Das ist aber sehr viel mit diesen Lungen, zum Beispiel mit COPD.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu auszufalten,
weil ich empfehle Ihnen einen Beratungsgespräch,
um diese Zigaretten auch zu hören.
Wenn Sie sich das nicht verhindern,
dann könnte ich Ihnen diese empfehlen.
Ja, können wir später machen.
Erst mal wissen, was mit der Luftnot ist.
Ja, seit wie lange rauchen Sie 20 Zigaretten pro Tag?
Also schon mal ein ganzes Leben, das dürften vielleicht zu 40 Jahre sein.
Okay, das ist aber sehr...
Okay, haben Sie schon mal einen ganzen Tag,
um die Zeit zu sein, um die Zeit zu sein, um die Zeit zu sein, um die Zeit zu sein.
Okay, das ist aber sehr...
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Lust um bemerkt.
Aber haben Sie Auswurf bemerkt mit Blutig oder Gäblich-Auswurf?
Ich meine, mussten Sie sich als sonst mehr diese Schleim produzieren?
Nee, also Schleimproduktion oder ja, als Raucher hustet man morgens,
aber so den Tag über habe ich nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie. Tricken Sie Alkohol, Herr Meier?
Nee, mit Alkohol habe ich es nicht.
Ja, ich glaube, Sie haben keine Kontakt mit Drogen, ja?
Nein, nein.
Sie haben gesagt, beide Familienmitglieder schon verstorben sind.
Das ist mir leid. Könnten Sie mir sagen, woan verstorben Ihre Familienmitglieder,
Vater und Mutter?
Also, mein Vater hatte, glaube ich, jengene Behirnblutung gehabt.
Und meine Mutter war einfach spontan verstorben, ob das jetzt ein Herzinfarkt war.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich weiß es, die haben nicht gesagt.
Okay, okay, aber da keinen Krebs entkrankt, wenn bei Ihrer Familie bekannt ist,
da ist es jetzt.
Nein, Krebs ist bisher nicht bekannt.
Okay, das freut mich. Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Meier?
Ich bin ein Rentner.
Okay, bitte.
Mit dem Rentner, ja.
Rentner, davor, als, wie, als was arbeiten Sie?
Ich war Lkw-Fahrer.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, richtig, ja.
Sehr gut. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne und eine Tochter.
Okay, ich hoffe, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Sehr gut.
Und ich glaube, Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Frau, Ihre Frau, ja.
Ja, ich bin mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja.
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt und ja, ich möchte über meine Planet,
kurz Sie über meine Pläne berichten.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperliche untersuchen, dann von Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Anschließend werde ich Sie einen Brustrundkern aufmeldet,
bei Brustrundkern aufmeldet, anmeldet und dann gegebenenfalls,
wenn wir einen EKG schreiben, um diese Herzritmus zu bestimmen und beurteilen,
dann eine Computer-Tomografie, wie in medizinischen Bereichen sagen.
Planen und mit allen Ergebnissen, wenn es alle fertig ist,
können wir nach dem, dieses Ergebnissen sprechen.
Haben Sie Fragen für mich?
Nee, nee, bisher, ja, ist okay.
Das heißt, ich muss hier bleiben.
Ja, ja, ja, ein paar Stunden, Sie sind hier bleiben.
Okay.
Okay, danke schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, mein Name ist Jürgen Bücker,
ich bin hier in die Situation Neuen Assistenzarzt tätig
und würde gerne einen neuen Patiente vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Okay.
Friedrich Maier ist eine 66-Jährige und ist am 15. Februar 1967 geborene Patiente.
Er ist 1,74 m groß und 78 kg schwer.
Herr Maier hat sich heute bei uns seit mehr als vier Wochen bestehende,
progrädierende Dispende vorgestellt.
Und er gab an, dass er innerhalb vier Monaten 20 kg abgenommen habe
und Sie erwähntet, dass diese Beschwerden bei der Belastung zum Beispiel
Treppensteigen und beim Gehen aufgetreten seien.
Und Sie klagte über...
Er, das ist ein Patient, ne?
Er, Sie.
Er fragte nach Angina pectoris und Orthopne und Endegefühl,
Fieber wurden verneint.
Sie klagte über seit mehreren Wochen nach Schweiß
und fragen nach Schmerzen bei der Wade
und herzger Tachikadi-Palkitationen,
wurden verneint.
Defekation und Mektion sind unauffällig.
Und Sie gaben, er gaben, dass er mehr als vier Wochen Fatigue-Symptome hat,
Müdigkeit, Abgeschlegenheit und Antiplosigkeit.
Und als sonst, ja, das ist alles für Sie.
Anvor Erkrankungen, leider er seit drei Jahren COPD, Lungen,
wie Sie es, bei den Patienten wurde keine Operationen durchgeführt
und als Dauermedikation, nein, er nehme keine Dauermedikation gegen diese COPD,
aber bei Bedarf nehme er Salbutamol spray einmal bei Bedarf
und bei dem Patienten bisher keine Allergien bekannt.
Er raucht 20 Sigeritzen pro Tag seit 40 Jahren
und das entspricht 20 Packungen.
Und Drogenkonsum auch sowohl langsam.
Wie lange raucht er schon?
40 Jahre.
Und wie viel am Tag?
20 Sigeritzen am Tag.
Ja, und wie viel Packungsjahre macht er?
Das bedeutet 40 Packungsjahre, nicht 20, aber 20, die haben nichts.
Und alle Drogenkonsum wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Bei der Familie an einem Niese ergab sich Folgendes.
Patze sei an subarachnoidell Benutung verstorben
und Mutter ist ohne organische Probleme verstorben.
Und Schwester und Bruder seien gesund.
Als Soziale am Nest, sie sei Rentner davor, als LKW-Fahrer gearbeitet habe.
Sie sei verheiratet, haben zwei Kinder, sie seien gesund
und er lebe mit ihrer Frau zusammen.
Mit einer Frau?
Ja, mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Als an amnestischer Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine bronchial Katzinoma hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Herzinsuccienz und Anämie auch in Betracht.
Ich würde sagen, ich habe keine andere differenzialdiagnostische Krankheit.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich diese folgende Untersuchung durchschauen.
Aus Kultation des Herz- und die Lunge.
Palpation bei der Beine, ob es hier Ödemen gibt oder nicht.
Dann Blutabnahme, Blutbild, großes Blutbild, Blutzucker, Blutgasanalyse.
Dann lebe ich auch Hypertrio, die ich mir das eine verdacht.
Blutgasanalyse habe ich es gesagt.
Man muss nicht sämtliche Differenzialdiagnosen aufzählen.
Wichtig ist, dass man strukturiert vorgeht.
Sie haben das wesentliche gesagt, er hat Gewichtsverlust, Luftnot, er raucht.
Also klingt das eher in Richtung Neoplasie.
Wichtig ist, dass sie ihn körperlich untersuchen, die Lunge abhören, ob sie da was auch völliges hören.
Dann entscheiden, ob sie akut notwendmäßig Untersuchungen machen müssen.
Oder ob sie so genannte Routine untersuchen, in die Wege leiten können.
Mussten wir erst mal in diesem Fall einen Tumormarker arbeiten, zum Beispiel CA19, CA15, wenn wir nicht noch verkiemen.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Man darf nicht ohne bekannte Krebserkrankung Tumormarker abnehmen.
Wenn Sie eine Krebserkrankung festgestellt haben, können Sie nach dem Tumormarker schauen, ob er erhöht ist oder nicht.
Aber Sie können keine Diagnostik mit Tumormarker machen.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Und zwar sagt er, er hat Luftnot.
Jetzt haben Sie den körperlich untersucht und hören den Mann ab.
In der Lunge merken Sie, so wie bei einer COPD-Defall, er hat Giemen, er hat so genannte grobblasige RGs überall.
Das ist aber gar nicht das Problem.
Sondern beim Abhören des Herzens fällt Ihnen auf, die Töne sind sehr, sehr leise.
Ja, Sie haben das.
Wenn die Töne ist sehr, sehr leise, Sie meinen.
Ja, die Herzgeräusche sind sehr, sehr leise.
Okay.
Erst mal bestimmte ich diese Vitalparamette, Zeichen, z.B. aus der Fizierung und Herz-Pitmus.
Wenn die Herz-Pitmus ist alles in Ordnung, z.B. 80, 90 oder so, werde ich eine ECO durchführen.
Ja, aber schreibe so erstmal ein EKG.
Nein, nein, ich habe es darauf gekommen.
Jetzt haben Sie bei dem Mann ein EKG geschrieben.
Ja.
Und Sie sehen, dass die EKG-Kurven sehr flach sind.
Man spricht von der Niedervoltage.
Oh, okay.
Ja, man sieht, dass das ein Dinosrhythmus ist, ist auch regelmäßig und hat ungefähr eine Frequenz von ungefähr 90 bis 100.
Und die Kurven sind sehr flach, also Niedervoltage.
Was meine ich?
Ich glaube, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Alle Welle sind auffällig, ja?
Keine Probleme.
Wir haben kein Echo, wir haben nur ein EKG gesehen, dass die EKG-Kurven sehr, sehr flach sind.
Die sind nicht so groß hoch und runter, sondern die sind sehr, sehr flach.
Okay, könnte es sein eine Herzgütmussturung, wie zum Beispiel vor Hoflehmann oder?
Nein, das kann man nicht sagen.
Wenn jemand eine Niedervoltage im EKG hat, dann müssen die Alarmglockenleuten.
Da hatte jemand schon eine richtige Idee gehabt.
Ja, die Pericardialtamponade.
Pericardegus oder vielleicht auch sogar eine Pericard-Tamponade.
Und sie haben einen Puls, eine Herzfrequenz von fast 100.
Und sie haben den Blutdruck gemessen und der Blutdruck ist gerade mal so bei 100 systolisch.
Das passt dann dazu.
Und jetzt müssen sie notfallmäßig tatsächlich doch eine Echokardiografie machen.
Ja.
Und jetzt schütten sie diesen Mann zur Echokardiografie oder der Kardiologe kommen,
macht das vor Ort in der Aufnahme und sagt, der hat einen sehr großen Pericardegus vor dem rechten Ventricle,
der mehr als 3 cm groß ist.
Und damit ist es mehr oder weniger eine Pericard-Tamponade.
Das Herz kann sich nicht füllen und die Auswurfleistung ist ziemlich niedrig.
Das erklärt auch, dass der Patient nicht belastungsfähig ist.
Sein Herz schafft es gerade in Ruhe, die Pumpfunktion aufrecht zu erhalten.
Aber wenn ein bisschen läuft, dann reicht es nicht aus, dann fällt die Sättigung ab.
In Ruhe muss die Sättigung nicht unbedingt abfallen.
Aber bei Belastung kann er die Sättigung deutlich abnehmen.
Er kann sogar synkopieren.
Wenn die durch Blutung, die zerebrale Durchblutung, die Sauerstofflieferung nicht ausreicht,
kann er auch bewusstlos werden.
Jetzt sagt der Kardiologe, dass der Mann gehört ganz schnell auf die Intensivstation.
Er hat eine Pericard-Tamponade.
Was macht man denn jetzt mit dem?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung für diese Falle, aber ich denke, dass keine invasive Eingriffe durchführen werden.
Weil es ist ein bisschen, ich glaube, gefährlich in diesem Herz eine invasive.
Können wir die Uretica vielleicht fangen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich sagen.
Das ist ganz im Gegenteil.
Sie müssen ganz schnell diesen Pericard punktieren.
Sie müssen das entlasten.
Sonst bleibt das Herz irgendwann stehen.
Dann stirbt der Mensch.
Und zwar können Sie vom Epigastrium aus, sub-sifoidal, sagt man,
können Sie mit einer Nadel einfach ins Pericard reinstechen
und da einfach eine Drainage reinlegen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, solche Notfälle müssen geläufig sein, weil das gibt es hier
nun wieder mal. Es gibt manchmal auch junge Leute, die kommen mit einer
spontanen Perikade-Agguss, weil irgendetwas gerissen ist, keine Ahnung,
manchmal so Sportlerherzen hier und da und dann kann es auch mal so
einen spontanen Perikade-Agguss geben und der muss ganz dringend
punktiert werden. Invasivemassnahmen ist die Methode der Wahl.
Nicht invasiv können Sie bei dem Menschen nicht helfen.
Sie legen da einen Schlauch rein und lassen das dann ablaufen.
Und was man immer machen muss, ist, wenn man jemanden punktiert,
egal ob jetzt Perikade oder Pleura oder eben Acidys-Punktion,
was muss man da immer machen?
Überwachen oder?
Ja, überwachen sowieso, aber aus dem Punktat meinen Sie, mein ich.
Wie muss man damit umgehen?
Perisieren oder aus dem Punktat?
Aus dem Punktat müssen Sie eine Analyse machen.
Wir gucken einmal, das schicken Sie einmal in die Mikrobiologie,
ob das ein entzündlicher Accus ist.
Sie schicken einmal in die Pathologie oder Zytologie,
damit Sie gucken, ob das ein maligener Accus ist.
Bei diesem Menschen haben Sie jetzt ungefähr 600 Milliliter Flüssigkeit entfernt.
Schon ordentlich.
Und der Pathologe sagt, er sieht darin maligene adenokarsinomzellen.
Damit haben Sie jetzt den Beweis, der Mann hat eine Neoplasie.
Und jetzt dürfen Sie die Diagnostik in die Wege nehmen.
Und wenn wir auf den Pericategus zurückkommen,
kann man auch eine Maßnahme durchführen,
damit der Pericategus nicht nachläuft.
Wie lange würden Sie dann diese Drainage im Pericate drinnen lassen?
Ich glaube, 6 Stunden.
Ich habe keine Inspirierung.
Man guckt, ob da etwas nachläuft oder nicht.
Sie haben ja den Beutel dran an der Drainage.
Und dann messen Sie jeden Tag,
wenn die Accusmenge deutlich abgenommen hat
und in 24 Stunden nicht mehr viel nachläuft,
dann können Sie die Drainage wieder ziehen.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Aber bevor Sie die Drainage ziehen,
was können Sie noch machen?
Einen Eco.
Eco können Sie wieder machen.
Eco müssen Sie hin und wieder machen.
Damit Sie sehen, hat sich das Herz erholt,
ist die Pumpfunktion wieder da,
gibt es andere Probleme?
Nein, aber ich meine,
gegen diesen Pericategus, damit es nicht nachläuft.
Egal, hier habe ich auch ein anderer Kollege hat gesagt.
Eine sogenannte Pericateverklebung.
Perklebung, ja.
Eine Pericardiodese, sagt man dazu.
Was macht man da?
Man kann ganz bestimmte Medikamente
über die Drainage in den Herzbeutel rein anspritzen.
Dann klemmt man die Drainage ab,
das Medikament kann nicht abfließen,
führt auf dem Pericate und auf dem Myocard
eine Reizung, löst eine Reizung aus
und dann verkleben die miteinander
und dann kann sich da keine Flüssigkeit mehr sammeln.
Das ist die Klemmung, ja, das ist die Verklebung.
Pericateverklebung.
Oder medizinisch sagt man Pericardiodese.
Gut, also, bei dem Mann hat man nach drei Tagen
eine Pericardiodese jetzt gemacht.
Und mittlerweile hat der Pathologe
die Zellen noch weiter analysiert
und sagt, das sieht aus wie ein Brontial-Adenokazinom.
Ja.
Und jetzt müssen Sie weitere Diagnostik machen.
Was gehört mit dazu?
Ja, es einmal noninvasive Wildgebegen untersuchen,
wie TORAX Tomografie, CT Tomografie TORAX,
dann eine Tor...
Ich habe diese vergessen.
Brontioskopierdoskogen.
Ja, Brontioskopierdoskogen.
Und wenn es möglich gibt es hier eine andere Tumorgewebe,
werde ich von dem einen Probe entnehmen,
um diese Pathologe zu sehen.
Und ja, wie mein Kollege hat gesagt,
ich werde eine Sintigraphie durchführen.
Und gibt es eine Stase oder nicht?
Um zu verrichten, aber bei gesichertem Brontial-Adenokazinom
oder verdachter Brontial-Adenokazinom,
reicht dann ein CT TORAX aus
oder müssen Sie noch mehr machen?
Ja, ich glaube es ist reicht.
Dann können wir diese...
Ah, MRT, für leichter Gebegen.
Sie müssen auch ein CT vom Abdomen mitfahren.
Weil es geht darum, Sie wollen jetzt natürlich herausfinden,
wo überall hin ist die Erkrankung metastasiert.
Wenn Sie von vornherein wissen,
der Mann hat einen malignen Perikatecus,
dann können Sie davon auch schon ableiten,
welches Stadium dieser Mensch hat.
Das ist nämlich schon ein Stadium 4,
wenn jemand einen Perikate,
einen malignen Perikatecus hat.
Also kurativ, bevorgehensweise wird wahrscheinlich nicht möglich sein.
Aber jetzt wollen Sie wissen,
wo überall hat dieser Mensch metastasiert, ja oder nein.
Den CT TORAX machen Sie, damit Sie sehen,
wo ist der Primarius?
Wo hat sich dieser Krebs gebildet?
Dann machen Sie einen CT Abdomen,
um zu sehen, ob die leberfrei ist,
ob die nebenirinfrei sind, ja oder nein.
Dabei können Sie auch natürlich die Wirbelsäule mit abklären.
Gehirn müssen Sie mit einem MRT abklären.
Drei Höhle von Dein Körper, drei Höhle.
Vor allem intrazerebral, ob es intrazerebralen metastasen gibt.
Und ob der generelle Knochenstatus befallen ist oder nicht,
machen Sie eine Skeletzintigraphie,
was der Kollege korrekterweise auch empfohlen hat.
Gut, jetzt haben die bei dem Mann MRT gemacht,
er hat keine Hirnmetastasen.
Und im CT TORAX sieht man im rechten Oberlappen
eine große Raumforderung, ja.
Okay.
Und er hat medialstinal vergrößerte Lymphknoten
und man sieht, dass die linke Nebenirin vergrößert ist.
Okay, ja, wenn diese Raumforderung und diese Tumor hat
scharf begrenzt und ohne Metastase in einer anderen Körperregion,
können wir als chirurgische Eingriff fangen, um diese Lobby zu fangen.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das hängt vom Stadium ab.
Sie müssen die Untersuchungen machen
und dann bilden Sie daraus ein Stadium.
Damit jemand operiert werden kann, dürfen keine Metastasen vorliegen.
Beim Bronchialadenokazinum gibt es Sosandesituationen.
Wenn isolierte Metastasen vorliegen, die der Operation zugänglich sind,
macht man das zwar manchmal, aber es ist eine Ausnahme.
Generell sagt man, eine metastasierte Erkrankung wird nicht operiert,
sondern das ist dann als palliativ einzustufen
und dann muss man dementsprechend über eine Chemotherapie
oder moderne Kombinationstherapien
oder zielgerichtete Therapien nachdenken.
Aber, was Sie jetzt machen müssen, wie gesagt,
erst mal ein Staging, wie wir sagen, ein CT-Torax, ein CT-Abdomen,
ein MRT vom Kopf, eine Skeletzsyntographie und eine Bronchioskopie.
Bei der Bronchioskopie hatte ich Ihnen eben gesagt,
der Tumor ist im rechten Oberlappen,
da wird man bronchioskopisch keine Probe nehmen können.
Aber er hat mediasinale Lymphknoten.
Darüber, von diesen mediasinalen Lymphknoten,
kann man manchmal mit einer Ebus-Untersuchung wissen Sie,
was ein Ebus ist?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nennt sich endo-bronchiala-ultraschall, Ebus.
Und dann kann man eine T-B-N-A machen,
trans-bronchiale-Lymphknoten-Bürbsee.
Und manchmal erwischt man die, manchmal erwischt man die aber auch nicht.
Und dann stellt sich in der heutigen Zeit die Frage,
geben wir uns damit zufrieden?
Oder machen wir noch mehr?
Heutzutage sagt man vor allem bei nicht kleinzelligen Lungenkarzinomen,
wenn es nach dem noch Karzinom ist, sollte man eine
molekulare genetische Untersuchung machen.
Da guckt man nach gewissen Mutationen.
Und manche dieser Mutationen sind mit sogenannten
zielgerichteten Therapien angebar.
Und dafür braucht man aber ausreichend Material.
Und die Zytologie kann manchmal nicht ausreichen.
Deswegen würde man gegebenenfalls aus dem Primaris aus
dem rechten Oberladen nochmal eine CT gesteuerte Probenkname vornehmen.
Okay, danke.
Das war alles neufig nicht.
Ja, was haben Sie immer gemacht bisher?
Welche Richtung?
Ich habe vier Jahre lang in einem Notfallaufnahme in der Türkei gearbeitet.
Jetzt habe ich hier in Solimgern einen Innere Medizin,
von Innere Medizin einen Vertrag bekommen.
Und warte auch meinem FSW-Puppen.
Okay, gut.
Also das ist nicht selten.
Damit werden Sie sehr viel zu tun haben.
Die innere Gekrebsabteilung gehört zu inneren.
Und in der Notaufnahme werden dann immer wieder solche Fälle kommen.
Und da müssen Sie sich auf solche Notfälle immer vorbereiten.
Also wie gesagt, es handelt sich hier jetzt um ein Broncharkarzinom
mit malignem Pericatecus oder in Anführung,
also Pericatamponade.
Die Notfallversorgung des Pericategusses steht im Vordergrund.
Und das weitere Staging mit Therapieanleitung wäre dann erst
im zweiten Schritt das wichtigste.
Gut.
Haben Sie denn bisher noch Fragen?
Nein, vielen, vielen Dank für alle Informationen.
Das war sehr viel.
Soweit verstanden auch die anderen?
Was ist etwas Unklares?
Haben Sie Fragen, Kollegen?
Keine.
Also die Kernaussage von heute ist, den Patienten richtig zuhören.
Wann hat der Luftnot?
Natürlich müssen Sie in meinen Richtung Kardial denken.
Und natürlich müssen Sie auch in der Notaufnahme
einen Infarkt-Ausschluss durchführen.
EKG, Herzenzüme.
Aber wenn Ihnen solch ein EKG vor Augen kommt,
wo Sie sagen, die Kurven sind sehr, sehr flach,
man spricht dann für den Niedervoltage,
dann müssen Sie mal im Kopf haben,
kann das ein Pericate-Guss sein.
Ja, und wenn der Patient symptomatisch ist,
dann warten Sie nicht lange, sondern machen einen Notfallecho.
Und wenn er dann eine Pericatamponade hat,
dann ist das etwas sehr, sehr gefährlich.
Das gehört sofort auf die Intensivstation.
In der Nacht muss man die kardiologische Rufbereitschaft anrufen.
Dann müssen die sogar reinkommen und notfallmäßig punktieren.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja.
Vielen Dank für die Emotionen.
Ich bedanke aber Ihnen.
Ja.
Ich wünsche viel Glück, viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank.
Bis demnächst.
Bis demnächst, Dank.
Alles Gute.
Tschüss und alle.